Everyone thinks anarchy is.
Do whatever you want.
A massive lesson
that I have gotten out of telling
this story.
Anarchy just means self-ownership.
The most peaceful ideology in
the world.
Was that there really
is no panacea.
Fuck the government.
Most of our people were buying into
bitcoin.
Coming in on private jets.
That is going to solve everything.
This beautiful paradise can
be a beacon of freedom for people to
migrate to.
What happens when a bunch of radical
individualists try to start a
community.
In Acapulco
Biggest Anarchist conference.
Trip to Mexico.
I'm really excited.
That is the subject of a new six
part HBO docu series
from director Todd Schramke and
his wife and co-producer Kim
Kylland. The pair spent six
years documenting and Acapulco
an annual conference for anarchists
started in Mexico by Jeff Berwick,
a political commentator who calls
himself the Dollar Vigilante.
All fiat currencies going to zero.
All markets just collapse and
closing.
I talked with Schramke about
how making the film has shaped his
view of anarchism and
libertarianism and what
the story of Anarchapulco can
teach us about how to launch
successful experiments in
alternative living.
I also asked him to reflect back on
when he found out one of its
attendees, a man who called himself
John Galton was murdered.
The anarchist, has been shot to
death. Tragic situation.
Rumors spread that other members of
the anarchist community may have
been involved.
There was some sketchy stuff
happening behind the scenes.
It really was one of the most
emotionally complicated
few weeks of my life.
I, I
mean, my wife and I
were that morning, the morning
of the murder going back and
forth with John and Lily and the
Freemans. We were texting all
morning. We were just two weeks
away, less than two weeks.
We're about a week away from our
next production trip.
And yeah, it was
all of a sudden they all stopped
responding.
And it was just shortly after
that I turned on Facebook
and saw that horrific footage
of Lily on her livestream.
It was just this really,
really intense feeling of knowing
this was going to change my life
in so many ways.
And the reason it was so emotionally
complicated is because
and it's one of the worst things
about being a documentary filmmaker
is that often other people's tragedy
can work to your advantage,
which is really blunt
way to put it. But it's true.
I mean, I knew this was going to
bring this story to a whole new
level of complexity and
interest, and it proved to be true.
And we were the
only people out there.
We had a small social media presence
at the time that was mostly for
engaging with the community and
people going to the conference so
they could know who we were.
And but because of that,
we were the only real outside
documentation of the fact that there
was this local community
that had emerged in Acapulco.
So we very quickly started
dealing with a lot of
press, reaching out and
trying to get our take on the story,
all while trying to maintain
and follow what was going on within
the community and
dealing with our friends and family,
all begging us not to go to Acapulco
again and fearing for
our own lives and safety.
It's been difficult.
It's been challenging.
It's it's fun at times, but
it has it's also made me question
if documentary
film is what I really want to be
doing, because it's
one ethical dilemma after
another. And in
some ways, that's what makes it more
powerful than a scripted
show. But it also comes
with a lot of struggle.
You said a lot of media
reached out to you after John's
death. You portray the framing
that the media was running
with. It's kind of obvious, you
know, an anarchist gets murdered
in Mexico doing anarchy
was. And that was kind of like
the the headline
that that you would see some version
of that.
Some people featured in the
documentary like Jeff Berwick
would say, you know
this his death really didn't have
anything to do with Anarchapulco
or anarchy.
It was kind of like his.
What he was doing outside of that
is what brought
that in.
There's this whole mystery
involving a guy
who may have been involved with
the hit that was put on him.
Like, how do you think about that?
How do you think about what
happened to John
and the relationship
with an Anarchapulco and,
you know, anarchism more
broadly?